Is the reason you're launching a
second product because you lost
all faith in the first one?
I think that happens a lot and you call it a
second product, but it's more of an
excuse to tell your investors or
the world that you're abandoning your
initial business.  If an excuse works for you
, go ahead and use it, but at least you
should be honest with yourself.
What is really going on
here?  Don't lie.
Are we a multi-
product company?  Yes.
This is Dalton with Michael, and today
we'll be talking about whether he should build
a second product.  What do you think,
Dalton?  I am the founder of a startup.
Yes. I
won't give you any more context than that.
Yes. Well, the answer is yes.  End
of video.  Uh, no, look, this is a
very common topic that
founders ask for advice on, when they have
something, their MVP, that does just one thing, you
know, let's say, widgets.  And they say, "
Should we sell this other thing
in addition to the widgets?"  And here are
all the reasons why it's a
good idea.  Yes. In theory, I think
I would need more information, but
perhaps to broaden the perspective, if your
first product is failing, adding
another product that usually fails
is not the solution, and maybe you should
pivot the entire company.  On the other
hand, if your first product is a
resounding success that grows
exponentially, and you have a very
good reason to want to add a
second one, then yes, the answer is maybe.
So, that's just my quick start
.  What do you think?
At this point, I am more pessimistic.  I think there are
two modes of failure, and I think you
described them perfectly.  And I think what is
n't talked about enough
is the failure mode where things are
going well and you don't build the second
product fast enough.
That's a failure mode.  Because I believe
that fundamentally, startups
try to compare themselves to their peers rather than to
incumbents
.  And often, when you look at the
incumbent, they have a set of
products, and if you're ever going to
compete against them, you need to have a
competitive offering.  So, let's look at the
example of Slack versus Notion,
right?  I think Slack never figured out
how to achieve this competitive set.
Microsoft Teams arrives and
Slack's business value drops drastically
.  Notion, on the other hand, I think
understands the game and says, and another
classic example would probably be
Google Docs.  And they simply think, if we do
n't have all the
office supplies, we're probably finished
.  And that's exactly right.
And it's curious to even mention
Microsoft, because Microsoft was
obviously a one-
product company for many years.
Yes.
And then they started adding more, and
now you don't see it as a one-
product company.  And Google was obviously
a one-product company for
many years until our friend
Paul created Gmail.  But why was it a
one-product company? For
six years?  And that's why it's kind of funny
if you're a one-year-old startup copying
the manual of a company that's been
around for a long time.
Yes.
Yes, they didn't even do what
you're trying to do.  Why would
you do it?
No, right?  So it's strange.  That
kind of failure is so strange when it's
something like, "Oh, we're winning."  And
then you realize: "Oh, no."  We are
competing against an incumbent and
we are like 1% of the incumbent.  Perhaps
we're much further behind than we
imagine because we never allow ourselves to
think that big. But I also think
there's something I see, especially in
venture capital, where you
basically have this product in
a strange phase of
product-market fit. Like when you see
descriptions like, "We have
product-market fit in a small market
." Or, "We have product-market fit
among customers who
like us."
With asterisks.
Exactly. Yes. And then, I see this kind
of game where sometimes a VC says to
a founder, "Okay, we have this
$20 million business."
Let's add another $20 million in
revenue and another $20 million." And then
, somehow, if we accumulate
enough $20 million
revenue deals, one day you can go
public. I don't think I've ever seen
that work.
Well, in hindsight, you can tell
stories that it worked, but
usually the main product is
a hit; otherwise, it's not a
second product, it's a pivot. It's like,
we can use whatever words we
want in hindsight. Would
you ever see a situation where you
've accumulated 10
mediocre products together versus situations
where definitely one of the
second, third, or fourth things...
Yeah... ...
blows up. I
mean, the example that comes to
mind is Posthog, which is a
multi-product company.
Yeah.
They launched multiple products pretty
quickly, but it actually makes sense
that it's a product suite. Their
initial analytics product was a
hit; it worked.
Yeah.
And it made sense, okay, you use Posthog
for analytics, let's do
session replay.
Boom, boom, boom.
Like that.
Yeah, yeah.  Yes.
I think it's a great
textbook case study on a
good multi-product setup. I'm not
going to name names for
negative stories, but we've seen a lot of
those.
We've seen a lot of those. If you're
DoorDash and you do food delivery well
, maybe you can do
store delivery, maybe you can do
grocery delivery.
Right?
Yes, yes, yes, yes. And pretty much if you don't
, someone else will. So
you have to. So,
there are probably a lot more examples
of companies that had an advantage and did
n't go all in, right?
Yes.
And maybe a classic one was, I think the
whole world got on Zoom during
COVID.
Yeah, God knows we did.
Yeah, yeah, hell yeah.
Yeah.
Um.
We were on Zoom all day, every
day.
Exactly. And I mean, I think it was almost
subsidized, wasn't it? Like the
government
telling schools to use Zoom
and the data, and as a
startup founder, that's a situation where you
just think, I don't want to
put it this way, but what  Good luck...
How can we transform this into a
lasting business so that when
the lockdowns end, we'll still
have a business?
Yes.
I think they tried, but as a
regular Zoom user, I don't think they
succeeded in getting people to adopt Zoom
for non-core uses. I think that's
a fair way of putting it. And
I think the tricky thing is, as a
founder, it's so hard when something is
working so well to say, 'I have to
shift my attention to something else.' And
actually, I think it's very scary, what's
really scary is that,
unfortunately, Zoom is a
classic office suite product. And we
've encountered this many times.
When you build an
office suite product, you're competing with
Microsoft Office and Google, even if you don't think you are
.
Yes.
If your ambition isn't to try to
become the next big
office suite,
I think my other example, that quick one,
is Peloton, where they had
brutal growth and tried a
lot of things. I don't think any of
it worked. And their
stock price isn't doing very well. But it was like, you
know, they realized
They needed to sell more things. But in the
end, it was kind of a
one-hit wonder. And I think that's really
sad because I think a lot of
founders say, "Those are
success stories."
Yeah. Well, and again, they are, and
kudos to the founders, hooray,
but they failed to transform that
exponential growth into
continuous, lasting growth.
Sadly, they had a fall.
On the other hand, Gmail was obviously
created by our friend Paul. That
worked, and he faced a lot of
internal nonsense, people who didn't
want to launch it and said it would be
a distraction. You know, you should
hear the story from him.
That's probably for another video,
but they launched it, and it was a
successful second product. It's still the
dominant email client, and I think it's
one of the most popular products
in the world to this day.
Yeah.
Google Docs is a monster. YouTube is
a monster. Hey, welcome to YouTube,
right? That's a Google product.
Wow, Google really did succeed at
becoming a
multi-product company.
Well, I think about this because I've
heard the PB story, and
there was definitely  There was resistance, but
once they saw that Gmail worked
, it seemed like the rest of their
office suite just fell into place—yes,
overnight. I remember in my early days as a
startup when I switched from Office to
Google, and I was thinking—I remember before
Sheets came out—thank goodness for
Sheets. Thank goodness for
Slides.
And a couple of those came from
acquisitions. Everyone forgets
this, but not all of it was
internal development. I think Sheets was an
acquisition, right?
Slides, and I think Docs too
. Google understood that
email is part of the suite.
Yes.
And I mean, my co-founders back then
were building the
calendar, right? Because when
Gmail came out, I think they realized
very quickly that it was part of the
suite. It's impressive how well
Google resisted that move and then
capitalized on it when it worked. The
last thing I'll say, which I think we
really want to emphasize, is this:
Shouldn't you be pivoting instead
? Right? Is the reason you're
doing the second product because you
've lost all faith in the  First?
I think that happens a lot, and you call it a
second product, but it's more like a
cover story to tell your
investors or the world that you're
abandoning your initial business. And
again, if a cover story is
useful to you, use it. But you should at least
be honest with yourself. What's
really going on here? I mean, don't lie
to yourself.
Multi-product company? Yes.
You can tell that story to whoever
you want, you know, it's your life as a
founder, but don't lie to yourself
.
No, I mean, we have this
example of Twitch where our old
product, Justin.tv, helped fund
Twitch. But I wouldn't say we were
a two-product company. That
would be going too far. There was a
main product. So, yes,
I agree. That's the kind of
uncomfortable topic that doesn't get talked about
enough: sometimes things reach $
20 million in revenue and then they stop
growing. So, um, just be honest
about it. Okay? Good job
.